why don't you describe for me as vividly
as you can what it is you're worried
about what it is that nightmare scenario
looks like fortunately there's very few
things and most of them are very low
probability you know some big volcanic
explosion gigantic earthquake asteroid
but they said the nuclear case you've
got to say we take it quite seriously we
budget a lot of money have a lot of
people who think about nuclear
deterrence and I'm very glad that works
being done and I read the chance of a
nuclear war in my lifetime is being
fairly low I rate the chance of a
widespread epidemic far worse than Ebola
and my lifetime is well over 50% we look
at the 20th Center and we look at the
death chart of the 20th century I think
everybody would say oh yeah there must
be a spike for World War 1 you know sure
enough there it is like 25 million and
there must be a big spike for World War
2 and there it is it's like 65 million
but then you'll see this other spike
that is as large as well or - right
after over 1 and most people a lot of
people would say what what what was that
there's two kinds of flus there's flus
that spread between humans very
effectively and there's flus that kill
lots of people
and those two properties have only been
combined into a widespread flu once in
history
well that is Spanish flu we have no idea
where it came from
it's called the Spanish flu because the
Spanish press was the freest they were
the first to talk openly about it
and so in the annals of epidemic history
that's the big event I funded a disease
modeling group that uses computer
simulation and that work has been
phenomenal in helping us target our
polio eradication resources and you know
which parts of Nigeria should we work
harder on and it's very natural if you
have a group like that to say hey look
at something like a Spanish flu in the
modern day health systems are far better
and so you think hey that wouldn't be
very bad well we tried it and there are
some assumptions we had to make but what
we showed is that the force of infection
because of modern transport which
compared to 1918 is over 50 times as
great and so if you get something like a
flu and you look at that map of how
within days it's basically in all urban
centers of the entire globe that is very
eye-opening that didn't happen with
Spanish flu in the past
[Music]
the opportunity to do more than just let
it run its course is really only in the
last decade basically when you talk
about for you so you can talk about
small molecules or talk about these
complex biological protein like things
which is a subclass called antibodies
antibodies are the molecules that the
immune system naturally builds to attack
disease today the idea that somebody
says oh here's the antibody make a lot
of it make it very quickly that's right
on the cutting edge and the Ebola
epidemic showed me that we're not ready
for a serious epidemic an epidemic that
would be more infectious and would
spread faster then Ebola did this is the
greatest risk of a huge tragedy this is
the most likely thing by far to kill
over ten million excess people in a year
we don't need to invest nearly what we
do in military preparedness this is
something where less than a billion a
year on Rd medical surveillance standby
personnel cross-training the military so
they can play a role in terms of all the
logistics here this can be done and we
may not get many more warnings like this
one to to say okay it's a pretty modest
investment to avoid something that
really in terms of the human condition
would be a gigantic setback
[Music]
you